hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
the köppen 19 pandemic has ravaged
economies all over the world again many
are questioning the very foundations of
the neoliberal order this is not an
academic exercise millions are hurting
and the worst is yet to come
does the Left have answers to discuss
this and more I'm joined by my guess any
Haiphong in New York he is a
contributing editor at black agenda
report as well as co-author of American
exceptionalism and American innocence a
people's history of fake news from the
Revolutionary War to the war on terror
and in Washington we cross cross to
Walter small our key is an organizer
with the answer coalition right
gentlemen crosstalk rules in effect that
means you can jump in anytime you want
and I always appreciated you know my
audience knows my political stripes my
leanings and they're very conservative
on most things but we live in very
extraordinary times right now and I
think it's quite obvious to admit an
honest person the old way of doing
things is not getting us in the future
in a good way we have what as we're
speaking right now 26 million people
have filed for unemployment now if you
look at historical levels this is
depression levels right now something
has to change Walter let me go to you
first here I mean if you were to give
advice to the powers that be what would
be the single most important thing you
would do well I think that one of the
greatest crises facing working people
right now all people in this country is
the crisis of housing people are up to
their eyeballs in debt to their
landlords I mean many cities and states
have moratoriums or de facto moratorium
on evictions and foreclosures but that
doesn't mean that you don't accumulate
debt to your landlord you don't
accumulate debt to the bank if you have
a mortgage and that goes for small
business owners too I mean people are
gonna be facing a potentially a wave of
foreclosures one
these emergency measures are lifted once
the quote-unquote economy reopens so I
think that's one of the principal things
that needs to happen right now the
cancellation of rent and mortgage
payments so that people aren't thrown
out onto the streets once the universe
passes or or even just the perception of
the worst passes because we may never
see this it's the worst the worst is
basically the end of the pandemic and
then you then we go into a different
phase of worse okay because people some
people hopefully the majority are not
being forced to pay their rent they're
not being forced to pay the mortgages
but they're gonna have to catch up this
is not you know you know it's not going
to disappear it's not forgiven okay and
I think and that's why I said in my
introduction the real pain is gonna
start once we see the end of the coming
of the end of this pandemic here you
know Danny you know just to go off on
what Walter was saying is that a lot of
these landlords they are actually partly
they have to pay their mortgage in their
payments to the banks you know I mean
this is this this cascade thing this
start going is gonna start happening and
unfortunately in my opinion and looking
back at 2008-2009 the wrong people were
bailed out then because they didn't need
to be bailed out they had plenty of
money and the wrong people have been
bailed out again okay and we all know
why it's special interests and
politicians in the pockets of big banks
and corporations this is just another
repeat of that but the difference
between the two crisis is is that the
real crisis as we get past the pandemic
is going to be the middle class and
working people and and and it's going to
be worse than it was in 2008 and 2009
because a lot of the jobs that have been
lost is likely that they're not going to
come back and I think that you know it
shows for me the the powers that be
particularly Congress let's go on
vacation is if they're not you know they
don't want to be held responsible
because this is gonna get really nasty
and really painful and you know looking
and I don't
I abhor the Republicans the Democrats in
equal measure so let's just get on get
that
out there okay but you know Nancy Pelosi
showing her ice-cream collection in her
twenty four thousand refrigerator and
let them eat cake mentality here I mean
it shows me that we need radical new
solutions but we have a lot of old
people older people that just can't see
in a different way out go ahead Andy
that's exactly right
and what I think the two-party system
here in the United States is showing is
that it holds in complete contempt
working people and it's only priority is
to prop up and maintain the rule of
Finance capital all of the measures that
have been taken so far this multi
trillion-dollar bailout that passed
earlier this month and all the bailouts
that have preceded and subsequently been
passed since have all been geared not to
assist working people and trying to get
through this crisis we have in New York
City a third of food banks closing lines
for food getting longer and longer you
have landlords who are checking IRS
information committing a federal crime
to spy on the so-called stimulus
payments that the cares act pushed
through in order to steal basically
steal their money right out from under
them the very few dollars that working
people are receiving in this crisis
landlords are seeking to take it because
at the end of the day all of these
bailouts have basically
institutionalized the ability of finance
capital to gobble up the rest of us
gobble up the rest of the so-called
middle class businesses the small
businesses as well as the remaining good
paying jobs that exist right here in the
United States and we're going to see how
damaging all of this will be when we
find that most working people had to
accumulate a boatload of debt just to
survive just to make it out and that
only leads to another and more vicious
economic crisis to come that's the
definition of an economic crisis
interesting that there's this almost the
surveillance states over the average
working person and family about their
so-called benefits from the state one
time off or whatever it is but there's
no oversight of these major corporations
Boeing
one of the worst run companies in
America today can't even make a plane
that runs but boy their checks showed up
real quick and there's no oversight
there's no outside member on the board
is it as it should be if they take
government money you know and then we
have Walter that for me this is the the
biggest tragedy of it all they even a
sin I would call it is it you tell
people don't go to work because you're
in quarantine used to have to stay home
okay so it's the state saying you can't
work well if you the state says you
can't work then the state has to
compensate you because you're telling
them they don't they can't go to work
okay
that's the way it should be and I'll
tell you as we get out of this people
that's good to be the top of mind thing
you told us not to work okay and it's on
you and and I mentioned this in my past
programs and I don't I'm not even the
person that likes to go to extremes but
I mean I think the word pitchfork is
gonna start coming to be top of mind for
a lot of no look what they did in
2008-2009 you know this is a one-off
thing this is amazing it will never have
me it's happened again it's happening
with greater frequency too and and
Danny's absolutely right you know it
just still another layer of the middle
class is being peeled away okay and then
you have this consolidation going on you
know we could have predators out there
taking over companies we're gonna have
less competition less entrepreneurship
which for me is a rough recipe for
disaster political disaster because
entrepreneurship is very important and
in a vibrant Society so Walter I mean is
this all happening right in front of us
here but I don't see that this is
there's no political imperative on the
part of the power should be oh
absolutely I mean I think that the the
system is being illegitimate in the eyes
of so many people I mean to your point
about oversight you know just just look
at the guy who's in charge of this
Stephen nooch in the Treasury secretary
you know not only was he a top executive
at goldman sachs he also founded his own
financial
and at that financial firm I believe is
called one West he earned the nickname
the foreclosure King during the 2008
economic crisis because so many of the
subprime loans that his corporation gave
out resulted in families being kicked
out of their homes and now he's the guy
in charge of dispersing these trillions
and trillions of dollars right because
in the Kerr is that you know
theoretically it's four hundred and
fifty billion dollars or so but really
when you add what the Federal Reserve
can do it's it's like ten times that
amount I mean and then there's the other
operations that the Federal Reserve have
rolled out since the crisis began new
chin and the head of the Federal Reserve
how they they're buddies they talk to
each other every day according to news
reports I mean this is an absolute
inside game where basically ex bankers
give trillions of dollars to their old
buddies you know and Danny mate the
banks that have been put in charge of
dispensing this they get their nice
little hefty cut to do it as well I mean
this is quite a more taxpayer money this
is funny money okay we're gonna see what
happens you know there no matter how you
cut it no matter how you cut it is gonna
be fewer jobs and higher prices no
matter how you cut it okay and again you
know going back to normal no folks
there's no going back to normal because
this is abnormal what we had before was
abnormal it has only become come into
greater focus just how abnormal this
system is against working people and
working families go ahead and in there
is no quote-unquote going back to normal
it's an impossibility because when you
just look at what has happened here you
have all of these banks being bailed out
and you have the economic landscape
basically changing under people's noses
while they're staying home trying not to
die of a virus which has absolutely
pummeled the United States especially
and then you have actual austerity
policies being pushed down the throats
of working people here in New York State
Medicaid was just cut to a tune of six
billion dollars during a pandemic and
Medicaid is a critical program for
especially working-class people in order
to just survive
this is the new normal the new normal is
austerity by any means necessary and
that's going to continue after this
crisis because the banks will be looking
to maximize their profits the
corporations will be looking to maximize
their profits and they'll be looking for
it off of the backs of workers if
there's no relief now there certainly
won't be any relief when the pandemic
settles and I think the capitalists and
all these big monopolist they know that
this isn't settling anytime soon because
it is they're putrid response and it's
their control over the state which has
caused this virus to spread like
wildfire in the first place and if they
make any mistakes they always know where
to go or they can fall you know and get
a helping hand put their hat out and you
have it filled up ok but not working
families here I'm you know Walter I
think you know future historians if
there will be future historians will
look back at this presidential campaign
and this pandemic and this was in and
from the Democrats you know this was the
party of the working people the party of
Franklin Delano Roosevelt and they have
a geriatric nominee that doesn't seem to
have all of his marbles together and his
outright said he would not pass a
single-payer a medical program for the
for the United States which is one of
the most anomalous things in the world I
I'm watching American political
discourse on that it's just so out of
whack and it's so out of out of ordinary
because most virtually all of the world
has that okay and I I'm old enough to
know and I was trained as an academic
historian I really get sick and tired of
people throwing around words socialism
okay and because it's just a slur it
doesn't doesn't mean anything other than
just to tar someone so I mean this is
the greatest irony as we speak right now
is that when you need to have a medical
program a health care program that can
service a population during a pandemic
and they're saying no
okay that we're not going to have that
and no and the powers that be don't want
it you know you can always say the
Republicans none of them want it okay
for the obvious reasons okay again out
of step with the needs of the average
person I mean if you look at the level
of health of average Americans it's very
poor because they don't get proper
health care from the very very beginning
if you had proper health care from the
very beginning and you could trust it
and count on it
you'd be healthier and then you'd be a
healthier worker and a healthier worker
would make more money and pay more taxes
there's kind of an intrinsic logic to
all of that that seems to be you know
just completely dismissed by the powers
that be
go ahead Walter yeah I think that's true
I mean it's a very explosive combination
for the elite that run this country you
have on the one hand the worst economic
crisis since the Great Depression
breaking out perhaps it'll be worse than
the Great Depression who knows and then
you have this political awakening of so
many millions of people and I think that
for all its flaws you know the Bernie
Sanders campaign was sort of the
principal vehicle at least in the last
couple years for that awakening to be
expressing on this idea this idea that
we have rights and you know to the
extent that that socialism has become a
popular word especially among young
people
I think it's an assertion of that basic
idea you know we have social rights we
have the right to health care we have
the right to education to decent housing
to a job to form a union at our job if
we want to to a living wage you know
these ideas are becoming a majority
public opinion and certainly within
particular demographics especially youth
people who are most likely to protest
historically these ideas are especially
strong so yeah at the very moment where
the system is trying to deprive people
of their rights on a scale you know we
haven't seen in a long time people are
beginning to become more and more
assertive of those social rights Danny
let's talk about a universal base the
income okay that's it's very contentious
you know I've already seen how the
powers-that-be react to it is that if
you give people too much money they
won't they won't look for a job okay I
mean I you know I come from very humble
beginnings and taking state money
was it was very very shameful okay in my
generation being brought up I'm a late
boomer for everyone to know okay so I'm
something you didn't do because the the
Great Depression was but my parents
experienced okay but with automation
going on as it is and and if people are
starving have no money no shelter then
you get into a political industry
instability you get into a point of a
revolutionary moment okay I mean you
you've broken people okay no one's gonna
listen to that kind of political you but
that's socialism that's what they do in
Venezuela that no one's gonna care about
that because we you know you know when
you're out of a job
I don't care what the GDP is or
inflation that you're in a depression
when you're out of a job you are in a
depression okay and when people have you
or in that situation you become much
more unhealthy we have alcoholism we
have suicide we have addiction all kinds
of problems here and if there isn't a
again my last few weeks of my programs
there I've asked home I guess how can we
reimagine the world okay and do it all
together I mean everything that Walter
said I'm willing to talk about and
negotiate we probably would have
different ways of getting there and this
is what I'm getting at okay we we there
seems to be this inability to set goals
say we want to we want to have people to
be healthy okay how do we get there okay
Walter might have his way I might have
my way and you know what I think people
of good faith would say well I see your
point I kind of see your point how can
we compromise that we need compromise in
a moment of where there's compromise is
considered weakness okay
and in cowardice this is the time we
need it most go ahead what I think is so
interesting about universal basic income
and the debate around it is that there
is a section of the ruling elite those
uh kerberos the B's OSes the Gates's who
believe that a universal basic income
would be adequate and alright so long as
it can be based on some sort of tax
structure that can actually rid of a lot
of social programs that they see as
cumbersome and that they see as
potential areas of profit for example
food stamps Medicaid etc
but on the other hand much of the ruling
elite despises a universal basic income
because they know that the
contradictions of their system
capitalism require automation but that
also a big profits are made from labor
that the supply chains are so wholly
dependent on ensuring the lowest cost
labor force as possible and so that
creates this very unstable economic
situation worldwide that a universal
basic income if implemented could have
workers thinking well why do we have to
work for such low wages in the first
place why do we have to continue to feed
the profits of this tiny tiny elite and
I think that's really where the debate
about universal basic income becomes
null and moot to the ruling elite we saw
a Nancy Pelosi oppose the care Zacks
provision to give some sort of stimulus
to workers on a monthly basis and part
of the concession of giving a one-time
$1,200 payment for people making ninety
nine thousand dollars a year or less was
because the Democrats opposed any sort
of monthly payment for workers to get
through this crisis and I think all of
the calculus was due to the fact that
their donors were worried about what
message that would send to working
people you know well I always get the
sense and I look at Congress and I look
at the political rhetoric is workers and
working families are just simply a
nuisance you know in this economy it's
the last thing you think about I mean
it's really extraordinary I mean I mean
the way I look at it you know we have an
economy to serve the needs and interests
of people okay that's why we have an
economy okay and if you looked at it
that way would be probably a lot more
equitable okay because obviously the
people that control the economy there it
is a a profit motive and the workers are
just in material I mean we could just
get rid of them I would be a great thing
the other thing is though on the other
side is that if you you do have this
universal basic income in a way it's a
return to some form of serfdom okay and
I don't think we need to go there as
well ok because that that's a lot of
control you have over people I don't
think most people want
for nothing I still truly believe in
maybe I'm just getting too old I think
most people want to feel productive and
I think they want to make decisions on
their own but when you have a crisis
like this like I said a few minutes ago
if you're telling people you can't work
then you have to pay them there's no ifs
or buts about it
go ahead Walter oh sure well I'm the
immediate point I agree with that I mean
I think we will need a replacement for
their income they need a decent income
these you know one-off $1,200 checks
that are for a lot of people just
immediately gonna go into the pocket of
whoever they're in dead leaving dead
yeah yeah exactly
yeah so that that doesn't cut it
whatsoever I mean you're you're a
broader point though I mean I think one
of the really profound conclusions that
a lot of people are drawing and are
gonna continue to draw from this crisis
is like who's actually essential in
society you know the phrase essential
worker it has this sort of like
technocratic like clinical like you know
meaning initially but then people really
internalize what that means I mean the
people who are essential other people
who work at grocery stores or people who
work on farms right you know people in
the food chain providing the most
essential things to sustain human life
you know the health care professionals
you know nurses other workers in the
healthcare industry people who are out
there saving lives every day sanitation
workers you know you know public sector
workers municipal workers who are
providing like sustaining support us so
that people can get through this they're
the ones who are really the most
important in society Jeff Bezos isn't
out there you know picking food in the
fields you know the the Bill Gates of
the world the Walton family if they
don't show up to work and they
frequently don't nobody notices it's
really working people who make the world
run and that's gonna be something that I
think really changes how people think
about themselves and thinks about the
way that society is structured yeah and
you have basketball players and and
baseball players they're all
millionaires okay they're all
millionaires okay and but but working
people are overlooked absolutely and
Danny what is the political implications
of this because of the Republican Party
the Democratic Party are in you know in
unison and not really wanting to ripping
their Anderson I mean there are
certainly individuals and then we'll
give them
right in for that I have to say that
maybe this is the first time since we
had Biden become the presumptive nominee
I have to express my absolute dismay
over Bernie and the way he's handled all
of this I mean history will not well
frown upon his behavior of the last few
months I mean maybe we'll find out there
was something there because I'm just
absolutely devastated by it I'm a
conservative bernie is not a
conservative but you know what Bernie
brought to the table a debate a real
debate and now the debate is gone all
right and that's tragic during this
tragic time during this pandemic and the
in the and the tsunami that's gonna
follow and we're not gonna have a debate
this is just lunacy go ahead and it's
going to fuel anger resentment and just
outright disgust with the political
system that is the future of US politics
in the United States it is that working
people are not going to engage in the
process and they have absolutely no
reason to engage in the political
process in the United States because
it's not even someone like Bernie
Sanders was tolerable and would be
allowed to win their rigged game fair
and square and I think that is so
damaging at a time and also when we
think about Bernie Sanders his response
his capitulation to the DNC only adds to
that misery and that resentment in this
time of crisis and I believe that there
are two directions that thinking this
can go and go into mass talut
disillusionment and mass resentment or
it can go into trying to build and
imagine an alternative to this political
system that is more conducive and more
responsive to the needs of working
people I am for the latter and not the
former but it is unclear which direction
it will go on Walter finish it up here
reimagine the world for us go ahead sure
well I mean just just to bring one other
element
this you know a huge part of the US
government's response to this in
addition to bailing out the big banks
and corporations is to escalate its
conflict with China so I think that when
we think about how you know society has
to change in the aftermath of this
coronavirus crisis we can't allow this
to become a mechanism a lever for the
Pentagon the State Department you know
the the Imperial establishment to
increase their their drive towards
global confrontation so I hope that the
world changes in the direction of
international cooperation and solidarity
the very interesting thing is that you
know I'm I'm a child of the Cold War it
was the preeminent political event of my
lifetime I remember it very very well
and the difference is is that the West
in its competition with the Soviet Union
and its allies is that there was almost
no trade okay there was this you know it
was such ideology ok the evil empire you
know imperialist America I mean it was
very much of a rhetorical level but this
interconnection this coupling here I
mean I I'm actually am enjoying watching
a lot of people squirm because you know
they they have to quote blame China
because well the United States doesn't
have a good medical care system ok it's
China's fault ok I'm not letting China
off the hook
no way ok but I mean you know going on
your metaphors
metaphorically going to war with China
will have consequences ok because what
do you build in America okay well we're
you gonna hit your TVs okay we're gonna
get your iPhones all right I mean you
know what I think would be a very
interesting reckoning while you have
these you know this this it's China's
fault
China is the new enemy here I really
hope and I'll finish off the program I
really hope there'll be real focus on
the people that sold American industry
to China I want them to be held to
account I would like to have a
commission on that okay I want to know
what their reasoning was how much money
they made and were they aware that they
were hollowing out America America's
working families on what I'd like to ask
them those questions okay I tended out
it's going to happen but this new cold
war with China is going to have a very
different wrinkle than it did with the
Soviet Union in the first Cold War I got
to finish on that point I used to be
university lecturer like
okay I want to pick my cousin Washington
in New York and I want to thank our
viewers for watching us here in our do
you see you next time remember across
that rules
[Music]